something I'm like genuinely curious
about so I see that on the screen the
notation says Knight G to F6 I'm
genuinely curious why that is as Knight
dm6 is not legal I thought that you
should just write Knight F6 that
annotation should just say Knight F6 so
many experts out there no I'll certainly
be curious to learn what the explanation
is
is this a philosophical question is this
a technical question I don't even know
where to begin I must admit I would have
written Knight gf6 as well I think just
out of habit of course not df6 is an
illegal move in this position due to a
pin on this Knight but this is where
Magnus was pointing out he played the
move Knight to F6 is the only night that
can reach there and shoot it what would
you have done which side do you want
this is uh yeah important life question
right now foreign